Welcome to Lee's Detective Agency.
We accept every manner of requests
and will do our best to meet your needs
in goods delivery, pickup,
infiltration, investigation,
arbitration, and conflict resolution.
We can solve *anything* in Lungmen.
And certainly,
except for detective work
because that's police business...
Please don't expect this to be a detective show.
Illuminating street lamps.
Lit up the city.
Criss-crossing neons,
and I begin to see.
The day just ended for someone.
And the day just started for somebody.
In empty streets I walked about
Confessing my boredom out loud.
I wanna keep feeling it
But you won't forget about this
Knock Three Times, before requesting.
I wanna keep touching it
Trouble's no longer a thing
When a future
You just waved to me.
A Cup of Tequila
This is a sculpture of a beaker.
A beaker is already a sculpture.
Why would you make a sculpture of a sculpture?
Well, you can place it next to your work bench.
Make things look artsy.
What do you think?
This gift's from me.
This is a toy for kids.
That's actually lots of fun.
I'm an adult. Can you at least give me something new?
We did give you different presents this year.
This is so boring.
Where are you going?
We... we received a request.
Can I go?
No. The place is for adults only.
I'm an adult today!
Let's start decorating.
Since you're an adult...
...if I can't make it out on my own, you'll carry me back to the agency office.
Roger that.
This isn't for you.
You'll just get milk.
Lee...
...when did you start letting kids tag along?
I'M NOT A...
Adults are talking. Play somewhere else, boy.
WHAT?!
I'll go look around.
I thought you'd come alone today, Lee.
Lee's Detective Agency might be able to help you out...
...but you did promise me intel about the Cat Mafia.
Intel?
We can hardly save our own skins right now.
We can handle that sum of money for you...
...that's open to discussion.
But don't push your luck.
The Cat Mafia is growing bolder by the day.
I don't even know where these strays come from.
I haven't even heard about them until recently.
Well...
...the Cat Mafia was around during the Rat King's time...
...but that was a while ago. And then they suddenly vanished.
This new Cat Mafia...
...are busy with some secret pharmaceutical trade.
They're into other shady businesses as well.
This Cat Mafia is nothing like the one we knew.
You're back, boy.
I'm not a boy.
Well then, can you drink?
HAH, I KNEW IT! You're just a boy.
Happy birthday!
I'll teach that brat a real lesson next time.
Next time, don't push yourself so hard.
It's his birthday. The boy thought he grew up.
Drinking and business should be kept far away from each other.
You have a hangover.
My head hurts.
Happy birthday!
Did I forget something?
Lee's D.A has been charged with the safekeeping
of a secret gold card for Mr. Meng the banker.
In return, Mr. Meng shall provide intel
about the Cat Mafia to Lee's D.A.
Both parties shall abide by the principles of voluntarism,
partnership, and good faith,
and observe strict confidentiality over this matter.
Ignore the useless nonsense.
Now for the important stuff: HAPPY BIRTHDAY, AAK!
To be continued...